aujourd'hui dans l'actu la voiture
électrique s'empare de l'espace public
depuis ce jeudi 50 Renault Tuy vont
circuler dans l'agglomération
cincantinoise 200 testeurs ont été
sélectionnés l'ouverture au grand public
est prévue en septembre 2012 une société
inimontaine a participé à sa conception
à l'occasion de la Fête de la Musique
portrait de l'entreprise D'Amico
Grégoire et son épouse ont déménagé de
Guill en cour à Buc et présentent la
guitare qu'ils ont conçu spécialement
pour Laurent vzi actuellement en tournée
la fête de la ville se prépare à montigi
le Bretonneux se sera pendant tout le
weekend en avant-première nous avons
rencontré les concepteurs des fameux
chars de la parade et puis un groupe de
champ choral à Manil etamo un groupe pas
comme les autres puisqu'il est constitué
de personnes atteintes de handicap tout
accueilli au sein du groupe gérondicap à
maniléamo
21 juin jour de l'été et jour de
lancement de la Renault tzy à 50 ans en
Eveline auprès de 200 testeurs une
flotte de 60 véhicules est mise à
disposition en autopartage et justement
pour permettre à ses voitures d'être en
libre service Renault a fait appel à une
PME locale ADM concept basé à Montini le
Bretonneux Guillaume vimon travaille sur
ce projet depuis le mois de février au
départ les voitures es sont pas prévu
pour ça
donc il y a des voitures qui s'adaptent
plus ou moins facilement on va dire et
après
bah vous devez modifier des pièces
intégrer un peu plus
d'électronique pour que les voitures
soient tout le temps géolocalisé il faut
mettre un lecteur
RFID un système d'autopartage intégré
dans le véhicule et après comme je vous
disais la
géolocalisation et après il faut voir
comment bloquer la clé par exemple sur
le le démarreur parce que vous le
véhicule au départ il est pas prévu vous
pouvez enlever la clé en autopartage
vous avez plus de clé c'est un batch
pour on on va dire ouvrir et fermer la
voiture une belle success story pour
l'entreprise créée en 1995 et qui compte
aujourd'hui 13 salariés bah par exemple
là on a C cette pièce est
une qui a été définie spécifiquement
pour Ty mobility pour en marquer deux
triangle de de signalisation Dominique
Leroi tient dans sa main une pièce
fabriquée en plastique qui vient
s'intégrer à la tzie là encore la PME a
réussi à décrocher un contrat dans un
secteur où la concurrence est surtout
asiatique pas si simple que ça et c'est
surtout très compliqué de continuer à
fabriquer des outillages de ce type là
en France c'est très difficile de se
positionner par rapport au marché la
concurrence est rude les achats les
achats vers l'Asie sont sont sont
importants donc nous on se positionne
encore dans grâce à notre réactivité ADM
concept équipe également en autopartage
des petites Peugeot et Citroën et suivra
de près l'avenir de cette Ty c'est une
voiture très agréable à conduire qui a
une accélération surprenante pour un
petit véhicule de ce type et le le grand
public pourra lui profiter de la Renault
Ty en autopartage à partir du mois de
septembre Laurent V a entamé la tournée
de son nouvel album l and love
accompagné de sa fidèle guitare lire qui
vous ne le savez peut-être pas a été
fabriqué à Buc par un couple de lutiers
renommé j'ai eu un coup de fil un matin
bonjour Laurent
voilà et il avait dans la tête un un
modèle VO qu'il avait du mal à
l'exprimer mais donc il est venu à
l'atelier on en a discuté c'était il y a
quelques années pour la tournée de son
album précédent avril depuis le chanteur
est resté fidèle à sa guitare faite sur
mesure là ce qui est sympa en plus sur
cet album c'est que il a fait des
musiques autour de l'instrument
l'atelier a aussi travaillé pour Francis
Cabrel Hubert Félix Tiffen ou encore
Charles Ellie couture côté
internationale non seulement Sting mais
aussi Mick Jager ont fait appel au
couple d'amicau un savoir-faire qui a un
prix par exemple rzi a choisi des
plaques par exemple plaqué or donc
effectivement c'est un petit peu plus
cher donc bon nous on osile je dirais
nos guitares osile entre 4000 et et 8000
€ l'atelier familial existe depuis 1995
et s'adresse aussi au particuliers en
proposant du surmesure mais aussi des
guitares en revente de toutes sortes et
ça vous arriv d'avoir des clients
bientôt dis an que l'association
montichard existe créée en 2003 quelques
années après la première cavalcade de
Montin le Bretonneux les montichars
comme son nom l'indique se consacra à la
construction de chars pour le défilé la
cavalcadeant disparu on s'est un peu
recyclé c'està-dire qu'on on fait aussi
des structures pour des des événements
de de la ville l'année dernière on a
fait tris énormes fraises cette année
les char participeront à la fête de la
ville de Montini qui se déroulera samedi
23 et dimanche 24 juin ils ont préparé
deux chars pour l'événement un char qui
est un char podium sur lequel il y aura
des animations faites par les centres de
loisir un autre construit sur le thème
du mouvement c'est une flèche avec
autour des ellipses qui représente en
fait des électrons qui tournent autour
d' atom ces électrons étant des les
activités de montig c'estàd le sport la
culture pendant le weekend de fête un
petit train circulera dans la ville et
s'arrêtera à différents points ces
stations d'arrêt ont été fabriquées de
la main des montichard au total une
quinzaine de bénévoles ont participé au
projet qu'il prépare depuis 2 ans tout
talent sont les bienvenus chacun y
trouve son compte il y a de la peinture
il y a de la soudure il y a du du bois à
travailler on utiliser du système papier
mâché c'està-dire qu'on des structures
métalliques avec du grillage dessus et
on passait du on passait des lanats de
papier et on collait du papier si c
couche de papier plusieurs ur parades
sont prévu samedi 24 juin le programme
détaillé est à retrouver sur
internet pendant 2 ans ces 17 personnes
en situation de handicap mental ou
psychique ont répété chaque semaine avec
un professeur de musique dans les locau
de gérandicap à manilé àamo pour pouvoir
se produire sur la scène de handy Blues
Festival de choral de l'île d'Oléron la
musique qui permet d'extérioriser ses
émotions et de se sentir valorisé le
fait de de pouvoir se produire devant un
publicah il y a les impréhensions alors
la montée d'adrénaline et puis ensuite
la la prestation et en récompense
suprême les applaudissements et ça c'est
un bonheur ben je me sentisis bien et ça
fait si longtemps que je suis pas monté
sur la scène alors j'avais un petit peu
un petit peu la pétage mais comme je
arrivé à la scène c'est vrai que j'ai
pris j' j'ai commencé à chanter
cine tout et après ça ça a été jusqu'à
la fin pour ne pas perdre la main les
apprentis chanteurs donnent des concerts
dans des institutions médico-sociales de
la région mais il rêve de retrouver le
public d'léron on a hâte d'y retourner
l'année prochaine avec d'autres projets
on voudrait intégrer une partie danse
aussi et en attendant de retrouver la
charante ses chistes répèt chaque jeudi
matin musique et barbecue les
travailleurs aussi ont droit à leur fête
des voisins mardi les salariés des
entreprises Sodexo et malakov m de gu en
cours sét donné rendez-vous derrière
l'école de musique pour un pique-nique
géant au-delà de l'aspect festif il
s'agit avant tout pour les deux entités
de symboliser leur rapprochement à
travers un projet commun on travaille
ensemble sur des dossiers communs du
territoire à travers le Plan de
Déplacement interentreprise à travers
l'association deltas et cetera et cetera
donc on se voit souvent et puis on s'est
dit bah tiens on est là en face de
l'autre il y a des échanges de personnel
il y a le personnel de Sodexo qui va
intégrer à la rentrée 150 salariés quand
même nos locaux on s'est dit bah
pourquoi pas on est obligé d'organiser
ce type d'événement pour que les gens se
renc compent ça peut pas se faire
naturellement
euh obligé non mais c'est
conseillé c'est la société qui est comme
ça he je crois qu'il faut fédérer au
travers d'un certain nombre d'événements
pour que les gens se rencontrent on
souhaite créer des réseaux mais des
réseaux je
dirais au moment de leur déjuner pour
que les gens se renconte physiquement
qui puiss échanger l'ambiance est au
rendez-vous chacun récupère son panier
repas sa mergaise ou sa brochette pour
pour une dînette entre collègues parmi
les salariés agès qui travaille depuis 5
ans au service pay de Sodexo elle est
ravie de l'initiative on pe connaitt pas
tout le monde non plus chez Sodexo donc
maintenant on va aussi connaître un
petit peu des gens de malakov et donc je
pense que ça va être ça va être chouette
non c'est une Eno des journées comme ça
sentiment plus mitigé du côté de
Sébastien du service informatique de
malakov bon le problème c'est qu'en fait
on reste un peu entre nous en fait mais
bon c'est quand même convivial donc
c'est une première fois que c'est c'est
fait donc faudra le renouveler quoi à
bon entendeur bon
appétit